um so i just want to say uh yeah
interruptions are great i mean i know
you you love them like more
um and the same is true for for boris
and me
um and especially from people who
haven't been like talking much
especially uh you know more junior
people
and uh and women
um i guess they're all junior here i
don't are there any
like
women with tenure here
yeah so like yeah please please
just interrupt and yell
thanks
all right um
before i continue let me first revise a
statement i made thanks to michael
nachmann i
now know that
actually reproductive isolation in
drosophila at least is very easy to
evolve if you separate to
populations
and they adapt to different environments
they can very quickly
um evolve within 20 generations right
that's what he said reproductive
isolation what's difficult apparently is
to evolve speciation
when they are well mixed and
continuously are allowed to mate with
each other to do this so that would be
sympatric speciation and that has been a
problem
so i'm not an expert so i know only very
little
but
these things in general
so um let me now focus on um
a very quantitative experiment which has
been running for a very long time now
it's due to richard lenski and it was
started in 88.
experiment is very simple and
it's a serial dilution experiment so
every day
so this experiment consists has 12 lines
of e coli and every day cultures are
propagated in minimal medium
so they grow for 24 hours and then they
are diluted
and transferred to fresh medium and so
on
since 88
and every 75 days of the 500 generations
roughly
mixed population samples are frozen away
so you have a
frozen
record a fossil record
of the evolution experiment
and then um
so since 88 now
over 55 000 generations have elapsed
and um
during this times a lot of interesting
results have been obtained using this
experiment
first of all
the main
observable that has been looked at
is the mean fitness of the both strains
relative to the ancestor
this is measured
in
boring way maybe i'm using the wrong
clicker
so this is the way you can measure
fitness
it has been traditionally done at least
without in the absence of a flow
cytometer
so
you have the ancestral strain and the
evolved strain at any given
generation time
mix them together
one to one
in a bottle and then
from that bottle already
and to make sure it's a 50 50 mixture
you plate
a small aliquot
a small amount of
that liquid
on a petri dish in a way
such that you can count single colonies
and now
this ancestor
has
essentially shines up
and can be seen as red
in this
medium here
so that on these plates you can count
colonies that are
normal in color and colonies that are
red
and by
and you can compare the ratio of these
colonies and from that ratio you know
the ratio
of cells the ratio of ancestor to evolve
in this bottle at time zero and then you
let this population grow for some time
and do the same procedure
and then um so apparently the evolved
strain are red on this petri dish
because now you see the
the fraction of red colonies has
strongly increased from this time to
that time point
and
from this increase in ratio of evolved
over ancestral
strains over this period of time you can
determine the exponential growth rate
of the wall strain relative to the
ancestor and therefore oops the relative
fitness
of those evolved strains
and
this is the result
of the experiment running for 50 000
generation
and you see
the relative fitness has continuously
increased
the rate of increase was very very
much stronger much higher initially than
later on but it's continuously it has
been continuously increasing what are
the two curves sorry the two curves
oh yeah these are um theoretical fits
to fit
um so that's a very recent paper that's
trying to understand why you observe the
slowdown
in
adaptation
so how do you count
count what
oh
um you look at it and count with in your
head
um so now there are automatic ways of
determining these ratios for instance
flow cytometers
with
which are essentially devices where you
have a small channel and cells are uh so
you you start you again
take a fraction of this um medium
containing the mixture of cells and then
these cells are
moved through a channel
and laser lighters shine on them
and and
if
one of them has a fluorescent then you
see when
the fluorescence come up
and you can essentially this this is a
mechanism of simply counting those cells
and uh this is now an automatic way of
doing this but this is sort of the
traditional way
this is i mean they don't actually count
them by hand i think i think there's
they have a computer algorithm that
recognizes the number of columns
probably probably yeah
so the y-axis is just the ratio of the
red
colonies to the
white colony
um
this is why x is here
no because here you have exponential
growth
in this period of time so you have to
take the long
actually to get at the growth rates
so what is depicted here is the ratio
of growth rates of derived strain
relative of exponential growth rate
derived to uh relative to the
to the answers of the experiment
ancestral doubling time divided by a
mutant doubling time that's also how you
can write it here
so why are there two lines
oh yeah these are
theoretical fits here in this paper
which try to understand why
you have the slowdown here
and um
they are arguing that it's consistent
with a particular type of diminishing
returns epistasis so the in there the
difference is that the originally they
used the power law the red line and that
predicted that it was going to asymptote
but now the new paper they're claiming
the blue line it's going to continue
increasing forever is the claim that
this new fit
works better
and it's different because it won't
asymptote right it's it's two different
models
of
the mutation supply something like that
and you're absolutely correct the red
one is one which would asymptote and
finally
stabilize and the blue one
goes to infinity but i'm actually not so
convinced based on this curve
well the blue one might be a better fit
but
i would not be surprised if the next
point lies here
you take away the last five then
well
so i wouldn't um
consider this as settled
all right
yes
sorry um
yeah i guess i was wondering what the p
values were because the standard errors
are
for both of them
i guess uh i i don't know i didn't want
to
point out actually this is a
there's a remarkable insight yet
actually no one pointed out that but but
i couldn't find a curve without these
fits so just ignore them
but what is remarkable i think is that
there was steady adaptation up to this
day for this many generations
and um
what is also remarkable is that there is
a diminishing diminishing returns um
so the fitness is
the fitness increase has been slowing
down over time
and i think of this in this graph what's
not depicted as one of the lines which
has evolved a key innovation of using a
different carbon source which was
present all the time in this medium
citrate
and at some point i think 30 something
generation
it evolved
a way to use that current source and
that gave it a huge
advantage in growth rate and that would
be a very strong kink i guess in this in
this curve and it's not depicted here so
this is more or less the background kind
of adaptation that has been going on
there
there's one exception
to it which is this
line that devolved citrate
citrate usage
yes
i thought that even in that population
the citrate users didn't actually take
over
is that true
yeah that's right yeah
yeah there's a i think there's a
coexistence between the
two
so so the non-saturated user is
doing has an advantage when it's rare
because it can use the other source
yeah i mean so i think actually maybe
the citrate population is in there
because i think in the this is measured
in exponential phase and i think
there they're just eating glucose
and it's only then they run out of
glucose and then the citrate users can
keep going so it may not even show up
here maybe
i'm not sure though
um
well
i think the prevailing
first insight is
rampant adaptation up to this point
and it's consistent
with
a measure this measurement for instance
which has tried to measure
the number of beneficial mutations the
rate at which beneficial mutations occur
in e coli populations
and their fitness effect
so in this
experiment
a deliberately small relatively small
population of e-coli e-coli have been
propagated
and
certain type of markers have been used
to
track down beneficial mutations that are
coming up and sweeping to fixation
and by analyzing
um
the
increase of these sweeping mutations
over time and their rates they could
come up with a histogram
of mutations
that come up establish and sweep in
these very small populations they argue
that this
histogram
is can be well well fitted by the
assumption
that
beneficial mutations are exponentially
distributed
and a beneficial mutation rate is in the
order of
2 times 10 to the minus 5 per genome per
generation and the typical
effect of these beneficial mutations
is on the order of one percent but of
course one has to keep in mind that very
small beneficial mutations really cannot
be
um
observed here it's
still the case that what what they can
observe are only mutations that are
sufficiently large to
take over but these results were
orders of magnitude at the time orders
of magnitude larger
than the
best estimates that they had before it
was
pointing in the direction okay that
there's a lot of adaptation
in these microbes and that's consistent
with this
evolution experiment by lenski and then
to me it's surprising that that's even
like a number that we can talk about
like what beneficial mutation rate yeah
because i mean naively you'd think like
okay it's it's it's adapted to this
you know yeah
it's certainly a function of the
environment
but also um
these raids they must come
with a cut-off with a cut-off of
beneficial mutations of effects that you
can actually observe and detect in your
experiment
so only this is the rate for mutations
larger than a certain minimal effect
size yes
total mutation rate is like
10 to the minus three yes
um
so
well
two percent of all mutations beneficial
on that effect
it
was surprisingly light this result would
presumably be different from if we think
about the slide you were just showing us
before if we did that experiment at the
beginning we might get this result if we
did it at the end we might get a
different exactly
and
it would be interesting to characterize
that and i don't know
whether this has been done although yeah
no i think
we also might not i think that they
don't
they don't
see any evidence of that i think i
i think what they see is that the uh
effect sizes of the beneficial mutations
go down over time
maybe this number does go down yeah yeah
and they're experiencing the system yeah
so something has to change yeah i'm not
sure if they saw uh if they're able to
see any decrease in the beneficial
mutation rate
i think they can be they can be but what
what is uh
constant over time so this was a
seminal study which
um
you know looked into the
nine again from the lenski group which
then took all the valve strain and
sequenced them thoroughly not all the
boston sorry and they i think they just
took
one line they chose one line
and sequenced
um
a clone from the from generation 20 000
and at earlier time points
and what they observed was that over
time
mutations
substitutions occurred at an almost
constant rate almost clock-like
almost what you would expect when
everything would be totally neutral like
kimura and well like the molecular clock
theory uh predict
so that can be seen on this plot
you should focus on the blue curve
so they're sequenced one two three five
four five
clones
and the number of mutations here
is almost linearly increasing with
generation time i don't know
probably some kind of
confidence intervals
and that was surprising and um perhaps
then you might think okay that perhaps
most of the substitutions that um they
saw and detected are perhaps neutral but
it turns out uh so first of all they
observed in the ancestor final uh sorry
the derived string 43 substitutions
and they they conclude that most of
these
substitutions are in fact beneficial
so i think they detected for instance no
synonymous mutation
at all
lots of different type of mutations they
observed snips deletions insertions and
so on that the principle can be seen on
this
picture here that's of course involved
but i think the main statement was
that really most of them are
beneficial i think that various lines of
arguing for this
also introducing some of these mutations
into the ancestor directly showing that
it's beneficial
and no
so they could
show for no mutation that it's really
neutral
so how can you reconcile
the statement and the the fact that most
of these mutations are probably
beneficial
and the fact that you have an almost
constant rate of substitutions well it's
consistent with very simple
models of adaptation
i'm showing here a movie in a second but
the model is really simple
it's the simplest dumbest model you can
think of
so imagine
you have discrete
fitness classes in your population
let's say here is log fitness
i'm plotting log fitness
and
it's increasing in
discrete
steps
2s and so on
and
at any given point of time the
population here has some distribution
on this discrete
lattice
and then in this model all that can
occur is
mutations
that
move an individual from one class to the
next class okay so these are beneficial
mutations and this model only beneficial
mutations are considered
they have a certain rate which
i call ub
and for that rate we take
the mutation rate that was measured in
this paper i presented by perfecto at r
the selective advantage let's also take
what is
what has been measured in this
experiment
and then
the only extra ingredients is
a fixed population size so the
population size is fixed and the
population size
in this model is fixed to 10 to the 8.
and as a response to now differential
growth of this population you will
obtain something that looks like a
moving wave
a wave that's moving towards higher
fitness
as you will see when i play this movie
so
there are several panels here
so
this panel simply shows
the number
of individuals in a certain class so
this is the histogram that
that i sketched there
and here i'm plotting the log of that
number
uh
this is actually a movie done by lucas
guyahu for a phd student of mine and
here we're imploding the log of that
number
and then here you will see how the mean
fitness is increasing over time as the
population is moving to the right
and this is an additional plot that
shows
the fitness variance over time which has
some oscillations
well the dynamics is
turns out to be
like this so
mutations are generated here in the nose
of the wave and they are coming up and
then
outcrowding the rest of the population
and the real important dynamics is going
on here in the nose that's why i'm
plotting the log so that you can see
here that it takes a while until a new
class
gets
colonized so here there are some
attempts to colonize it but then they go
extinct and eventually if they are
sufficiently numerous
they increase and
takes over until it takes over the
population
and this leads to a dynamics
where the wave where this population is
moving continuously at a more or less
constant rate towards higher fitness
and the rate at which mutations are
um accumulated is constant in this model
so there is an adaptive model can you
freeze this sorry is this a way to
to freeze this or yeah or no it's okay
we can look at like i mean the thing
that strikes me about this is okay so
you're saying population size of 10 to
the eighth but then down at the bottom
of the graph we're talking about like
single individuals right zero yeah
that's one here yeah
yeah so you've got like a population 10
to the eighth and then if we catch it at
a point where you know that front bar
right there is like down at the bottom
uh
yeah we're talking about single
individuals or a handful of individuals
and we wait a few generations
everyone else the population has died
they've done nothing they've contributed
nothing and the whole population came
from just those few individuals yes
it's kind of you know so it's it's
pretty striking i mean everything that
was going on in the vast majority of the
population had nothing to do with what
will happen
uh just a few generations down the road
that's according to this model yeah
and there will be more about models
in
the next lecture so i don't want to
spend too much time on it but why
there you go there you go okay
um
so these models they explain
the clock-like behavior of the
substitution dynamics
another way to
view these dynamics
is by looking at these kinds of plot let
me explain them so if you have
these
even this simple kind of model
you have two very different dynamical
regimes
so one regime is
you can imagine the population size
being very very small or the mutation
rate being very very small
then the dynamics that's happening is
you most of the time nothing is
happening and you have to wait a long
time until a mutation comes in
and establishes survives genetic drift
if it does that
then it grows exponentially to fixation
and then you're waiting it again until
the next mutation arrives and
establishes
so that's a regime which is called
periodic selection where the waiting
time
for a new mutation to come in and to
establish is much longer than the time
for a mutation to sweep to fixation
and then you get these successive sweeps
which are depicted here so to understand
this plot you have to imagine that you
line up the whole population
along the y-axis
um forget about genotype frequency at
this point
and then mutation mutation comes in at a
let's say random individual hits a
random individual
and then it establishes it takes over
and this plot is
don't think too much about the details
of yield mutations always come in at
exactly the same in the video but
um the key point here is that
you have these
successive sweeps that are coming in and
it's very easy to understand that in
this scenario the rate at which you
accumulate beneficial mutation
is simply linear in the population size
the reason is simply that the larger the
population size
the more beneficial mutations come in
and
higher than
the rate at which beneficial mutations
sweep and reach fixation
now when the population size becomes
very large or the mutation rate very
large then you enter a different
dynamical regime
which is much
harder to understand
where beneficial mutations
are coming in at such a high rate that
they also come in on different
backgrounds
and then
start to compete with one another for
instance here
so we have a first suite
which generates
this this purple clone and then um
a mutation comes in and establishes
which creates this blue clone and
another mutation on also the purple
background
comes in and starts to establish you
know these two clones at some point have
displaced all the rest but they are
still competing with one another for
going to fixation and which one
which of these mutations goes to
fixation depends on future mutations
that are coming in
but you see from this plot
that is impossible
uh for
both blue and orange
to reach fixation on the long run one of
them has to die
because there are different backgrounds
and there's no mechanisms that can bring
them together in the same background
and
this kind of competition between clones
and between beneficial mutations
leads them to the fact that in this
dynamical regime
the
speed of adaptation depends
logarithmically only logarithmically on
the population side and also
the haitian rate
and it's it's a it's a huge effect it's
a huge effect on the adaptation speed so
rather than being proportional to the
population size you have something
that's logarithmic in n
and it has been argued that perhaps sex
has evolved
in order to
have a mechanism that is actually able
to bring mutations beneficial mutations
that live on different backgrounds of
the same background
if you then have if you have sex in this
context then you can in principle if you
do this sufficiently often you can go
back to this other regime and you still
assume that all mutations are simply
additive as it is assumed in this
model but that's of course just one of
the i think 17 hypothesis of why sex is
good
also here you see you can get funny
dynamics in the allele frequency of
these clones for instance
the blue one here
the blue mutations if you follow the
the frequency of the blue mutation
in this dynamics it it goes up and first
looks like yeah this is really
beneficial it will probably take over
but then it
gets stabilized because another mutation
came in the orange one
which is equally strong at first and
then these frequencies are stable
but then the orange
mutation
the background with the orange mutation
gets another beneficial mutation
which pushes these up
so the purple curve also comes in
and purple and orange are both going to
fixation and blue is driven to
extinction
and
now interestingly
so this this can be tested in
experiments as well so that's an
evolution experiment done by desire
fisher and murray where they vary the
parameters the key parameters in this
in this model namely population size can
easily be varied but also mutation rates
can be varied by looking at mutator
strains which have by factor of 100
higher mutation rates
and what they found is consistent with
their
prediction
also more recently michael desai
actually has a paper where
they looked at the really the dynamics
of these mutations and they can actually
verify these funny trajectories here
um
how long do we have until
45 right yeah um i mean we can take
extra five minutes for questions but we
don't have to okay
um
i have a couple of more slides um
on the so this is a variant of an
evolution experiment with e coli so so
far
we have seen
the
landscape evolution experiment
and the sequencing paper that i
presented just sequenced
one line
and
um
and and at intermediate time points now
here we have an evolution experiment
also involving e coli
involving e coli that was adapted to
high temperature to 42 degrees
and that evolution experiment only ran
for 2000 generation
in the first 2000 generation you also
found in the landscape experiment the
fastest kind of adaptation
but what's sort of new in this
experiment is that you have many more
replicates one order of magnitude more
so 118 lines
were
parallely evolved
and
at the end of the experiment one clone
of each line was sequenced
and they found
a lot of different mutations in these
different lines so for each each line
had roughly
accumulated a mutation on the order of
10
to 16 i think mutations
but if you
pooled all these lines then they found
over a thousand different kinds of
mutations and again here
there are different lines of argument
why they think most of these mutations
are
beneficial first of all you wouldn't
think mutual mutations
in this kind of experiment to become
very frequent
but also for instance the dnds ratio in
of these mutations uh was very very
large so the expectation is that 80
percent of all of these are beneficial
and what's what's surprising of this
study is that there are so many ways of
increasing your fish
their your your your fitness so many
ways of
getting mutations that increase your
fitness
and but they also
if they look somewhat broader at the
level of genes and in particular
functional modules they found some
parallel evolution
so that's shown in this plot here
what you see
is the average fraction of shared
derived alleles between replicates
and for at the level of mutations
this
fraction of shared alleles is very very
small
um
but then when you go to the level of
genes
it increases to already 20 and if
you go to
so if you if you think about
genes
which which consists of many different
loci and you just ask the question which
genes
have been mutated in the different lines
and um
then you find
that
across lines
there's a large amount of um replication
so a large amount of genes that have
been
uh mutated multiple times
actually that's what i don't know does
anybody know but all are just two i
think it's right two or three i don't
think it's by
it's a small number
um
i
haven't seen one in this paper yes how
many jeans are there
um
five thousand i think yes
five or six
so what's the
nps oh the ratio of um
sorry
exactly
thank you
all right um
so to finish
with these
microbial experiments
for now
um
so let me mention some other lessons
that have been learned so there's a lot
of adaptations oh okay wait i just
checked so the the sharing is the
average
fraction shared for two randomly
selected lines
so it's actually it's actually much
higher
yeah
so in this experiment relatively rarely
one observed evolution of a key
innovation so
the one that has been found is highly
celebrated but it's really just an
instant evolution
of aerobic citrate usage
after 30 thousand generations
there is on the level not on the level
of mutations as we've seen in the
previous paper but on the level of genes
and modules
there's a lot of parallel adaptation
detected
and
also there seems to be a general pattern
of diminishing returns of the stasis
between beneficial mutations
um but i think the last five minutes
um
so we have five minutes for questions
right that's what no plan is yeah yeah
there's any like major
big points about fruit flies
i don't think so so so here i just
wanted to mention
uh this paper that did a similar kind of
study like the tanayon study
on um adapting fruit flies
um and here it was selected the fruit
flies were selected for faster
development over 600 generations
observed the 20 increase
and
the prevailing pattern
of genomic adaptation there was
soft sweeps so um
here they started
with standing variation in their
evolution experiment they could observe
that um
most of the adaptation seems to be
driven
by pre-existing
variants increasing frequency
and they suspect that
at least for their experiment the influx
of beneficial new de novo mutations
was relatively minor
i think with that
let me end and if you have more
questions
please ask them
come on why do you think the um this
model you described on the board uh that
you described as kind of like incredibly
simple why does it do reasonably well at
describing
almost certainly isn't kind of step like
increases in fitness
um yeah you can generalize the model
to
and consider a general mutation kernel
that you're assuming here
and a
mutation kernel that
is not like a delta function so that you
advance always by the exact same amount
of fitness you have
you're drawing from a broad distribution
of mutational effects
and
there are then differences that you get
in the precise predictions
for the rate of adaptation but these
differences they cannot be
verified with the experimental data but
what remains
the same is really the very weak
dependence for instance on the
population size that's essentially
logarithmic that
is really almost independent of the
mutational kernel where you put
so that that is a very strong effect
predicted by the
mutation
by the model and also observed in the
experiments
yes is this distribution of mutation
classes similar as for male structure
well in malas ratchet
in the basic models
exactly
i i don't know i mean also in the
miller's ratchet case i guess you have
to ask yourself what happens if i have a
broad distribution of deleterious
fitness effects but i think the basic
model for milo's ratchet also just works
in a staircase way like all mutations
have the same effect
but i guess one should generalize it and
ask what happens with i think it
probably depends on the regime you're in
the
the product of n and mu like for
mullah's ratchet and similarly for added
forward take adaptation
you can have a regime where
you're
if you're in the regime that's sort of
on the borderline of where mueller's
ratchet happens
then this like broad distribution might
not be a good approximation but if
you're in the regime where there's lots
of deleterious mutations entering for
generation you might have this broad
but this broad distribution of what of
fitnesses
is that that's that i think it was the
distribution of
mutational fitness effects
yeah mutational classes in the
population
i think yeah but that that is
the choice of a modeler you can you can
assume something about the
mutational fitness effects and one of
the simplest
assumptions is to say okay all mutations
have the same effect so that's why it's
typically started with that
and basic knowledge ratchet works
based on that
but you can and probably should ask the
question what happens if i have a broad
distribution
what i was talking about which is in the
population
in this model here you're it's
when the beneficial mutation is high you
have the distribution of fitness classes
in the population at any one time and i
think when people model mueller's
ratchet you can have if the
you can be also in a similar regime
where there's a distribution of fitness
classes in the population at any one
time and so not so but you you're
worried about the fitness distribution
of the population whether it's broad or
very narrow i'm not worried about it
yeah okay but no david you're commenting
on that but i think his uh comment was
on a different kind of distribution the
distribution of
fitness effect mutational fitness
effects
from which you draw the mutations
that you let follow in your population
this question was
is in the mueller's ratchet case that
gives a similar universality that if you
put in a broad distribution of mutations
you get a similar result if you use a
staircase model that's my understanding
at least right that i don't know um and
i i don't know the answer here
is different you know because
you lose always
the zero cloud the best class by drift
and so you get a very strange
distribution which goes so it's leaning
towards the right and i'm not sure what
the situation is here i guess in
mueller's wretched it very much depends
uh
on this distribution of uh deleterious
fitness effect if you have a very large
rate for very weakly deleted mutations
then you can hardly avoid i guess one is
ratchet to click
because of those because selection is
not efficiently pruning those
very weakly
deleterious mutations but i don't know
the mathematical
formulas for this just pretend to be an
experimentalist at this point
later
analyzed mother such and i'm not sure
whether he used similar techniques that
you used here
i might be talking
yes i don't know the stage
it's prepared for boris i think though
yeah but this yeah i think
he's a good guy to ask if you want to
but that's maybe a little technical um
so
i think we have time for like if there's
a broad question from someone who hasn't
talked yet
um
yeah
i'm encouraged by the suggestion that
complete novices can ask questions yeah
uh sorry this is naive i had the
impression from ross moose nielsen's
talk that at least the evidence that we
have about animals isn't inconsistent
with a lot of neutral
mutations and here the evidence from the
bacterial colony suggested that
i guess you wouldn't see deleterious
mutations persisting but at least that
there aren't very many of the mutations
that they saw that were neutral is this
a difference between bacteria and animal
is this a difference between the type of
evidence that's an excellent question
and i think it's an open question
um so what we've done here and looked at
here for now and what i presented are a
particular type of lab experiment and
the question is to what extent does it
translate to nature and if you think
about nature in these experiments there
are obvious differences that come to
mind
one that i'm working on and wasn't able
to present that's the effects of space
so right now these experiments are all
well mixed all cells are
coupled to one another
and competing with one another and um
and that can be realized very well in
these experiments and it makes all the
analysis much much easier
and therefore it's sort of a starting
point for these things and it's well
deserved it's a reasonable starting
point but the question is when you put
in space perhaps it's different and
there are
certainly certainly situations
where
chance genetic drift is much more
important than in these well-mixed
populations for let me just show this
one slide
so if you for instance take
two strains of
e coli bacteria and they're labeled
differently
and you mix them together and you create
um
a well-mixed initial condition
and you you spot a small droplet
of that
population on a petri dish
and then you grow the colony then on the
white light it looks boringly round
but if you turn on fluorescent light you
see
this pattern
and so in the center you still have this
mixture and then
but as you go out everything is demixed
and you have clones of different colors
and there is
also an adaptive explanation for this
you know the adaptive explanation would
be okay a beneficial mutation
came in which is very strong for
instance here on the greenback
background and therefore the green
background expanded or beneficial
mutation occurred here on the red
background therefore the red one
expanded and so on
but actually all of this is neutral
and and it's very easy to verify you
just pick from
the edge of for instance here the red
sector and back compete against the
green ancestor
and
in the same way and what you generate is
exactly the same pattern statistically
so this is all due to noise that is
occurring even though there's a
humongously large population
and that's an effect that's introduced
by space
and
and it's it's not present in well-mixed
models and
at this point to me it's unclear which
of these effects are
important and what situation
in nature so so we are right now
carrying out evolution experience in
this kind of setup to also see whether
we can observe
adaptation
when we grow colonies repeatedly so we
grow a colony sample from the colony
inoculate a new one
um
and so on can we observe
rampant adaptation or not it's not clear
to me
okay and this is just one effect
these experiments they still evolve them
for long enough compared to the mutation
rate to see neutral mutations it just
takes longer so like in the lenski
experiments there was one that uh
mutated to have a much higher mutation
rate and then they saw tons of neutral
mutations
in the drosophila experiment where they
start with a lot of diversity almost all
those mutations are neutral
it's just with these ones where they
start with
clonal no mutations at all a beneficial
mutation happens it spreads to the whole
population a neutral mutation happens
it's just in that one individual you
don't have a chance to see it it takes
too long
anyway i just wanted to have the last
word hey
so thank you very much